there was one time while he was
president a guy tried to assassinate him
the first
attempt on a president the gun uh
misfired he pulled out a second pistol
it also misfired andrew jackson now
furious this guy's trying to shoot him
twice took his cane and beat the guy to
a pulp andrew jackson could have fought
12 duels could have fought a hundred
they're not sure yeah he didn't have no
idea but he likes to fight out there
yeah he like to go at it
what if you were just every time i do a
duel i'll shoot you immediately
yeah i mean that's not honoring and
you're like yeah honorable defeats the
whole purpose i guess and then you're
like but i'm
not but i won yeah but i won and he's
not yeah the other guy's dead i'm not
yeah so i
what's the what's the problem you know
what's the that's he just what's the
problem i don't understand
yeah would you like to
ask ask him who won